wow
he fights well he plays really really
well with
just a few seconds on the clock but i
mean the way i'm failing to
[Music]
uh to convert here is
is awful
[Music]
this is going to be a molding stream
i'm sure people already knew that but
this is going to be
a serious molding stream from now on
okay this line i used to play myself
back in the
good old so-called days
i i've had this as black against vishy
for instance
usually white is a little bit better
b3 maybe black usually has to go queen
b6 at some point in exchange queens and
then
you know there's not much but there's a
bishop there
okay we'll take it bishop d3
c4 just push base6 and then d5 i think
so i'll try bishop e3
thinking of this this
i can win a template with c4 later on
maybe i'll go knight c3
this way fc1 there's still night before
i think i can do i can go c4 though
rp4 bishop p2
d5 i'm definitely a bit better here
basics i got a3 knight c6
cd5 and i should be better
hmm
another line i'm thinking of here is
dc4 bishop c4 bishop d5
trying to exchange then i'll go a3
bishop c4
ab4 bishop b3 rook c8
and then ba5 with a better end game
obviously that point is pretty much now
that he's gone king of eight
so if a3 knight c6 cd5 is got knight d4
line doesn't necessarily end there but i
don't think it's too promising for me
yeah let's go a3 let's publish p3
if he goes d4 i go back and i start
pushing these pawns
that should be much better
and bish basics i got cd
maybe i should play dc4
pc4 i think rp1 later on
i'm definitely better question is how
much
wait a second maybe i could have gone c5
here
i guess it doesn't matter now
c5 okay never mind
just
[Music]
play it cool for the moment
i have a very nice positional edge
let's go here intending c5 then before
i think he has to taken cfr or now at
some point
maybe bishop a6 was a good move
if i go c5 then he blocks that's no good
let's take on a5 at least i i do get a
past outside pawn here like i had in one
of the previous games
do i want a dark squad or light square
bishop
it's not actually obvious to me which
one i want
okay let's go for the light squared one
i'm running out of time so
i think we're okay and i should hold
yeah it's definitely holding after
looking at this i should have exchanged
one pair of works
i assume this is fine as well
probably change now
knight f5 what the hell is that
he's not getting the knight where he
wants
no this was no good night
d7 sound like a rook d7
this reckoning is massively
advantageous for me i feel like this
must be winning
okay let's exchange this one first
it's not winning is it
no it's not winning
okay okay